Terron dean attorney here over here i
want you to read these off lonely
selfish start attention seeker shut
people out
now you know all this has had a bad
impact on her I hurt you by
internalizing things and not sharing
things with you look at Tara look at
anything I'm very bad at speaking things
and saying things and I just do the Dean
thing that I do and turn on the
character that I can become I just think
that in my heart you should know exactly
how I feel about you
and know how much I love you how can I
know when you're making all this show
for everyone and I'm not included that's
that's me that's not you it is me always
not me with us what I do things that
makes me shut off shut up you don't even
let me talk look like a local to be
partners in friends with you
all of a sudden Sedin may show she's
suing everybody okay you're right you're
having fun on the fun we've stopped fun
together
and now I feel stabbed in the back
coming up on marriage boot camp reality
stars
I'm not happy I'm disappointed in us
let's just end it like really end it
though they cut yeah that's this
furniture to make at the prom
I'm not doing this